the most common form of dementia for
people under the age of 60 is a disorder
a few of us have ever heard of 60
minutes revealed the devastating
consequences of frontal temporal
degeneration also known as FTD last
night it attacks the part of the brain
that controls speech and personality and
it's frequently misdiagnosis
Alzheimer's disease Parkinson's disease
or depressions the majority of cases
occur in patients between 45 and 64
years old that's young 60 minutes
correspondent Bill Whitaker introduces
us to a family in the middle of a very
painful fight he went from being a
caring doting father and husband and it
just seemed like he'd flip the switch
off and he had no idea that he'd changed
he had no idea Amy Johnson and her
husband Mark married in 2006 settled in
the small Minnesota town of Windham and
now have four young children three boys
and a girl
three years ago Amy says Mark suddenly
seemed to stop caring about her and the
kids that's the first time that I really
remember thinking to myself what
happened where did you go
amy recalls a day when she left mark in
charge of their son's then three and two
only to come home and find the boys
playing outside alone by a busy street
while Mark sat inside watching TV
oblivious on other days he began to
display compulsive behavior she had
never seen before he couldn't stop
eating I started locking the food up he
would walk down to the grocery store and
buy more I took his credit card he'd
walked down to the grocery store and
steal food I mean these changes that you
saw did you ask him what's going on yeah
he just said oh I don't think anything's
different is it it was mark began making
inappropriate remarks to a female
co-worker at the company where he worked
as a manufacturing engineer he was fired
mm-hmm his reaction was oh well I guess
okay so what's for supper tonight what
was your reaction I was just devastated
that was seven months pregnant at the
time with her daughter with your fourth
child with my fourth child dr. Edward
Huey is associate professor of
psychiatry and neurology at Columbia
University in the Taube Institute for
Research on Alzheimer's disease and the
aging brain and he joins us at the table
you were telling me that this is your
specialty and I have to say I'd never
heard of it either most people hadn't
until we saw 60 minutes last night why
don't we know more about it and how
common is it yeah more common than
people think there's really much less
awareness of this disorder than there
should be
it affects about 50,000 people in the
United States it is the third most
common neurodegenerative cause of
dementia or dementia is a progressive
cognitive disorder and actually the
number one cause for people under 60 of
dementia by that age group we don't know
something about the biology of the
illness but but we don't know why that
affects that group what are the warning
signs well so you know I think there a
couple reasons why there's not as much
awareness one is that the people when
people think of dementia they think
memory and they think older people and
these are different so this is these
people tend to be younger and then the
symptoms are very different their memory
tends to be pretty good the symptoms I
think you heard a little bit about from
the family are changes in behavior and
personality being the main one they can
do very strange things bizarre behaviors
you heard about him stealing and they
don't know they're doing it they don't
know they're doing it so one of the the
hallmarks of this disorder is a real
lack of awareness on the part of the
patients which again you heard in him
where they don't think anything's wrong
with them so what is this being either
misdiagnosed by doctors or just what
have we been calling this one we've seen
them so it's very commonly misdiagnosed
very commonly so sometimes there's
Alzheimer's these even more often as
psychiatric disorders so you can imagine
the scenario where someone's middle age
they start withdrawing they start acting
differently they get sent to a
psychiatrist psychiatrist diagnoses with
depression and then the common story we
hear is the family will say you know
something's not right with dad he can't
work his cell phone he can't he's doing
these business are things then they get
a brain image the image is abnormal and
they get referred to a specialty center
where they're diagnosed does it affect
the longevity of your life oh yes it's
it's a fatal illness hey yes the the
main course of the average course the
illness is eight years to death
no cure yeah in general what can we do
all do to keep our brains healthy so I
think that there are things we all
should be doing in and you know they're
they're not going to be new answers in
some ways which are exercise mental
activity but then I think there's a
particular impetus for us to kind of
identify these non Alzheimer's
dimensions which are rare or often get
misdiagnosed so that they can get
referred and for treatment
now we don't currently have treatments
for this but I think we will soon
there's a lot of exciting trials going
on but the treatments aren't going to do
us any good if we don't get them to the
people who need them but I would also
think if the behavior changes that
drastically you're embarrassed to even
discuss it so that's a big reason
there's less awareness is that these
patients unlike a lot of illnesses our
patients can't really advocate for
themselves because they have the
cognitive problems the personality
changes their stigma the patients are in
Barre I mean not the patient's the
families are embarrassed I mean I very
much applaud the family that spoke in 60
minutes because we need more families
speaking out but the families are often
and I can totally understand why this is
they don't want this to be public
because they think well the person they
were before would be horrified at how
they're acting and which is true it's
not their fault you know one of the big
problems with the misdiagnosis is also
these bizarre behaviors initially are
offered to interpret it as volitional
they're just being bad they're there
then they often lose their job yeah they
lose their insurance even though they're
sick and they have trouble getting it
back and then they often will get
divorced and so once that that real the
the true diagnosis of frontotemporal
dementia is made obviously it's an awful
diagnosis but it allows us to correctly
interpret what they have it now maybe
somebody listening to you and watching
60 minutes will see it differently yeah
that's the hope that's the hope thank
you dr. Ted thank you good to have you
here